[Música]
y con él vamos a hablar de la reciente
tensión en la frontera entre ucrania y
rusia que se remonta a 2014 en la región
del donbass al este de ucrania que se
encuentra inmersa en un conflicto que ha
dejado ya más de 14.000 víctimas
mortales la anexión de crimea por parte
de rusia el 18 de marzo de ese año
desencadenó entonces esta serie de
movimientos que han hecho de esta guerra
en ucrania un conflicto diplomático
internacional y es que las tensiones
entre los dos países están en su punto
más alto en años con informes de una
acumulación de tropas rusas cerca de
esta frontera que alimenta los temores
sobre una posible invasión de moscú y
por ello entonces le doy la bienvenida a
nicolás de pero él es analista senior
del institute for state craft de londres
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de frança 24 nicolás le
pregunto entonces cuál es la situación
actual en esa frontera que tan posible
es una invasión rusa a ocaña
bueno desde el punto de vista material
en función del despliegue realizado
rusia las últimas semanas y que sigue
incrementando las últimas horas y en
tanto en cuanto a
digamos que usted ha lanzado un
ultimátum a eeuu y la otan que entiende
que no ha sido no recibe una respuesta
satisfactoria
y aumenta digamos su retórica agresiva
pues todo indica que bueno todo apunta
que la posibilidad de que rusia lance un
ataque masivo y devastador contra
ucrania pues es relativamente alta ahora
bien si lo van a hacer o no esto la
última palabra la decisión sólo la
conoce el presidente putin ahora nicolás
rusia realmente está dispuesta a mediar
qué es lo que quiere rusia y por qué
evita a toda costa que ucrania se una a
la otan moscú tiene alguna potestad o
digamos esta posición de decir usted si
se adhiere al otan o no
no claro lo que está exigiendo el
kremlin es
precisamente tener derecho de veto sobre
ucrania y más países porque las últimas
semanas lo que han dicho es que hay que
volver a la realidad anterior
a 1997 cuando se firmó un acuerdo a lo
que se llama el acta fundacional entre
la otan y rusia es decir que todo esto
puede afectar a todos los antiguos
países del que forman parte del pacto de
varsovia más suecia finlandia estas
últimas semanas también a medida que
aumenta la agresividad rusa hemos visto
que se reactivaba el debate tanto en
suecia como finlandia el debate público
sobre la posibilidad de solicitar su
adhesión a la alianza atlántica y esto
inmediatamente ha generado amenazas por
parte de rusia no y esto claro es el
principal combustible pero desde el
punto de vista del derecho internacional
pues evidentemente no asiste a rusia no
no no es legítima su reclamación cosa
que no se piensa en términos de pasado
imperial y entiende que tiene derecho a
una tutela estratégica sobre varios
países vecinos en este caso
singularmente ucrania pero sería lo
mismo en el caso en el caso de
kazakhstán o en el caso de otros y aquí
el principal problema ni siquiera es lo
que diga la otan o la unión europea es
que estos países en particular ucrania
no están dispuestos a aceptar esta
tutela estratégica esta es la razón por
la que llevan siete años combatiendo y
en guerra no hay por qué y por la que es
tan difícil salir del impasse
diplomático lograr una solución
satisfactoria para todas las partes el
crimen también ha dicho que no planea
invadir ucrania y que no representa una
amenaza pero realmente como lo ve
ucrania y occidente de digamos a rusia
como una amenaza contra la seguridad de
europa y también de occidente
si el kremlin ha dicho que no planea una
invasión o un ataque pero bueno no sería
la primera vez
digamos en los últimos años hay una
constante en cuanto a bueno pues que
digamos las declaraciones públicas de la
diplomacia rusa no suelen ajustarse a la
realidad de los hechos cuando estaban
llevando a cabo la operación de anexión
de crimea también estaban insistiendo en
que ellos no estaban en crimea también
hoy en 2022 la oposición oficial de
rusia sigue siendo que ellos no tienen
nada que ver con lo que está sucediendo
en el este de ucrania y esto es bueno
pues es más que difícil de creer y lo
cierto es que sólo hay un actor en
europa que bueno está dispuesta a
desatar una guerra y a cambiar el statu
quo unilateralmente y por la fuerza y
tiene los medios la voluntad política y
veremos si decide finalmente hacerlo o
no pero es una posibilidad real pero
anticipar los imposible la medida que es
una decisión exclusión de manos de rusia
nicolás ya estamos hablando entonces la
posición de rusia pero ahora le pregunto
por la posición de ucrania y de
occidente frente a esta amenaza rusa
bueno ucrania en estos siete años no ha
dado ninguna muestra de estar
pensando en rendirse pero hasta ahora no
ha afrontado una amenaza de esta
magnitud en las dos ocasiones en las que
ucrania las fuerzas humanas se han
enfrentado abiertamente a las fuerzas
regulares rusas y los enfrentamientos se
saldaron con derrotas masivas para las
fuerzas ucranianas batalla de globales
en agosto de 2014 y de walser en febrero
del 15 y son las que condujeron las
firmas de los protocolos de minsk o sea
que digamos el asunto el contexto no
pinta nada favorable para la posición
ucraniana y del lado europeo tanto en el
marco unión europea como en el marco con
el mar que son distintos nombres el
marco de la unión europea
veremos no pero digamos la división y
discrepancias entre los estados miembros
y dentro de cada uno de ellos con
relación a cuál debe ser la respuesta y
la relación con rusia pues ese es su
principal debilidad y no permite que la
unión europea adopte una posición de
firmeza que generaría alguna disuasión
pero no no no
y en el marco también sabemos que no va
a haber una respuesta militar
esto se ha dicho os he dicho
explícitamente tanto reino unido como
eeuu y bueno veremos lo que sí que habrá
claramente es un refuerzo de la
seguridad de los miembros más expuestos
es decir aquellos que están más próximos
al territorio ruso nicolás le preguntó
por los otros factores que están aquí en
este en este juego digamos de tensiones
y de presión qué rol juega en este
momento de la expresión tuca ucraniano
petro poroshenko que regresó al país
justamente en este momento de tensión
porque lo hizo en este momento y por qué
decidió regresar entonces a ucrania
ahora sí a enfrentar la justicia de ese
país
bueno esto es un asunto
paralelo no directamente relacionado
aunque es probable que poroshenko trate
de aprovechar esta tensión porque
evidentemente visto desde fuera y el
tipo de indicaciones que le van a llegar
al gobierno del presidente es el en sí
es que no en fin que concentre su
atención y sus energías en hacer frente
a una amenaza de extrema gravedad que se
cierne sobre acciones sobre el país
ucrania digamos esto tiene que ver con
que ucrania en el proceso de reformas y
de transformación de la realidad
institucional y jurídica del país a
partir de las de la reducción del euro
maidán en principios de 2014 bueno pues
no ha producido todavía los resultados
leo unos resultados plenamente
satisfactorios y la clase política
ucraniana pues sigue enfrascada en este
tipo de confrontaciones y sigue una
dinámica que es particularmente nociva
que es la de que quien no tiene el poder
suele acabar perseguido o sufriendo
consecuencias
y esto
bueno hace más difícil que se adopte una
general for mixta o que los actores
políticos de relevancia
pues tengan un incentivo para que se
adopten reformas de calado que permitan
ver un verdadero reino de la ley no
imperio de la ley del contexto ucraniano
esto es esto digamos un factor
particularmente problemático que
debilita y que desde luego rusia va a
explotar todo lo que pueda tanto en
términos informativos como en términos
de influencia dentro del contexto
ucraniano donde todavía tienen bueno
herramientas y vectores por los que
expandir su influencia